in diesem Hybriden Blockseminar der
zweiten Hälfte geht es wieder um
Theorien der Gerechtigkeit wir hatten im
ersten Block die klassischen Theorien
ganz zurückgehend auf Platon und
Aristoteles wir haben gesehen dass bei
platongerechtigkeit ganz stark auf den
Start bezogen wird der wiederum erklärt
wird aus der Verfassung der menschlichen
Seele genauer der menschlichen Seelen
Vermögen der Seelenteile und
Gerechtigkeit lässt sich beim Platon
dann also individuell auslegen als
Tugend einer Person oder auch kollektiv
als
Eigenschaft vielleicht auch Tugend
Tugend ist ja ein sehr weiteres Konzept
den griechischen als Tugend einer
Gesellschaft die
Funktionsweise ist so dass Gerechtigkeit
als Funktion von Harmonie verstanden
wird also wenn jeder mobilen Teil
dassjenige tut in Anführungsstrichen was
das seine ist also was sein tellos ist
oder sein seine Aufgabe ist dann tritt
als Effekt aus dieser Interaktion der
jeweils ihre eigenen Arbeiten erledigen
den Seelenteile die Gerechtigkeit hervor
und genauso ist es auch im Staat wenn da
alle drei Stände also die Philosophen
der Widerstand die Wächter und der
nährstand zweimal die Bauern wenn die
alle dasjenige tun was ihr eigenes Ziel
ist was ihr Werk ist ihre Aufgabe ist
dann tritt als
Effekt oder fast schon immer geht daraus
Gerechtigkeit so kann man zumindest
erklären wir haben uns auch gefragt wie
das Verhältnis von Staat und Seele zu
verstehen ist ist es nur eine schwache
Analogie oder ist es tatsächlich so dass
die Seele oder alles Seelen aller
staatsmitglieder
oder genau gesagt die Seelenteile aller
staatsmitglieder dass die die kollektive
Gerechtigkeit
konstituieren dass die also am Werk sind
die einzelnen Seelenteile um gemeinsam
im Zusammenspiel dann so eine staatliche
Gerechtigkeit zu erstellen also ganz
spannende Fragen die man sich hier
stellen kann wir sind weiter zu
Aristoteles aristoteles hat ja sehr viel
Wert gelegt auf die Tugend individuelle
Tugend und er unterscheidet verschiedene
Arten von Tugenden Tugenden die man
erreichen kann indem man belehrt wird
das sind die dianoetischen Tugenden oder
um da darum geht es bei der
Gerechtigkeit um ethische Tugenden die
durch Gewohnheit und nicht durch
Belehrung also durch Praxis erlangt
werden gebildet werden und in der Regel
durch die richtige Mitte
von extremen des Beispiel ist hier immer
Tapferkeit als richtige Mitte von
Tollkühnheit das ist das zu viel und von
dem zu wenigen das ist dann die Feigheit
jetzt kann man sich fragen ob die
Gerechtigkeit ebenso eine Mitte ist
zwischen Extremen und das ist ein
bisschen schwieriger jetzt die
Richtigkeit wird gemeinhin immer als
Gegenteil Negation der Ungerechtigkeit
verstanden also nicht als so eine Mitte
zwischen zwei Extremen man kann aber
Gerechtigkeit dann wiederum als Mitte
verstehen wenn man sagt gerecht ist
diejenige Person die nicht zu viel gibt
oder zu viel Macht und die auch nicht zu
wenig macht sind die ist eben angemessen
macht und wenn man das so sieht dann
kann man sagen dass Gerechtigkeit
eigentlich in jeder anderen Tugend
enthalten ist die die gesunde Mitte
macht weil Gerechtigkeit formal nur
anzeigt dass es einfach die gerechte
Mitte ist und wenn alle anderen Tugenden
die richtige Mitte definiert werden dann
kommt natürlich der Gerechtigkeit eine
wichtige Eigenschaft zu die ist zu sagen
die konstruktur die allen Tugenden
zugrunde liegt man kann also sagen dass
die Gerechtigkeit eher formalen
Charakter hat während die anderen
Tugenden eher konkreter sind Tapferkeit
und so weiter Gerechtigkeit ist viel
abstrakter als Tapferkeit zum Beispiel
also das ist interessant ist Verhältnis
die Gerechtigkeit als Tugenden
Verhältnis zu den anderen Tugenden gibt
es dann häufig auch diese Redeweise von
der sogenannten Kardinal suchend
die wurde dann im Mittelalter wichtiger
bei Thomas von Aquin da ist immer nicht
so darauf eingegangen wir sind dann eher
weitergegangen zu Thomas Hobbs der dann
eben als einer der ersten Gerechtigkeit
versteht aus den Verpflichtungen heraus
die wir eingehen und er sagt Unrecht
oder Ungerechtigkeit gibt es ohne
Verträge gar nicht wenn wir keine
Verträge haben können wir auch nicht
davon sprechen dass etwas ungerecht ist
das interessante Wendung die dann auch
bei Rosso weiter verfolgt wird er
unterschied Naturzustand wo wir noch
keine Verträge hatten und der Vernunft
Zustand wo wir eben durch unsere
Vernunft Verträge ausgehandelt haben
aber eben auch uns dadurch immer
verglichen haben mit anderen Menschen so
dass dann Unmoral in die Welt kam also
eine eine auch auf die Gesellschaft so
eine Gerechtigkeitstheorie und auch auf
die Geschichte des auch noch wichtig
Gerechtigkeit aus der Geschichte
herauszuklären wir sind dann
weitergegangen zu Johns wird wir haben
untersucht wie sich Gerechtigkeit und
Nützlichkeit zueinander verhalten
gemeinhin hat man ja die Intuition das
Gerechtigkeit mit Nützlichkeit nichts zu
tun hat also dass wir nicht
Gerechtigkeit über
nützlichkeitserweckungen versuchen
sollten zu erklären das ist ja irgendwie
nicht so im Sinne dieses Heeren Ideals
der Gerechtigkeit wir sehen dann aber
schon mit Müll eigentlich auch beginnen
so eine Kritik der Gerechtigkeit die
dann sich vor allem auch bei Friedrich
Nietzsche gezeigt hat der gesagt hat
Gerechtigkeit ist gar nicht so eine
Heere Idee seine Heeres Ideal sondern
Gerechtigkeit ist einfach ursprünglich
ein schlechter Kompromiss gewesen weil
wir einfach zu bequem waren um uns immer
mit anderen
kriegerisch zu einigen wenn wir den
Eindruck hatten andere Parteien sind
ungefähr genauso stark wie wir dann
haben wir aus Freiheit einfach uns
darauf verständigt uns nichts anzutun
und haben dann diese ja diesen
feigheitskompromiss am Ende dann
Gerechtigkeit genannt also diesen
Egoismus dass wir eigentlich nur an uns
denken den haben wir dann am Ende so
stilisiert dass wir so taten als zweites
eine ganz große moralische Tugend dabei
ging es uns einfach nur darum dass wir
möglichst ungeschoren davonkommen zwar
beide Parteien die im gefegt gleich
stark ist also Gerechtigkeit ist ein
wirklich sehr aufgeladenen normativ
aufgeladene Begriff den wir immer auch
kritisch betrachten müssen so viel jetzt
zum Rückblick es gibt auch ein Quiz das
mache ich dann unten in der
Videobeschreibung hinein dass man online
ähm versuchen kann mit Fragen die immer
auch erweitert werden jeweils zum
Seminar das war als ein Rückblick und
jetzt geht's aber mal weiter was will
ich noch mal kurz eine Einführung geben
und die Thematik die ich jetzt auch ein
bisschen ergänzt habe
man muss verschiedene Begriffe
auseinanderhalten und das hilft uns sehr
auch die jeweiligen zu lesen also
Gerechtigkeit und Ungerechtigkeit das
Seminar heißt ja auch Theorien der
Ungerechtigkeit also wir müssen immer
schauen wie verhalten die sich
zueinander ist die Gerechtigkeit ist die
nur die Negation der Ungerechtigkeit
anders gefragt ist die Ungerechtigkeit
die Negation der Gerechtigkeit was ist
vorrangig es finden wir ursprünglich
immer Ungerechtigkeit und indem wir sie
ausgleichen kommen wir zur Gerechtigkeit
oder ist es andersrum dass erst
Gerechtigkeit da ist und dann ein Mangel
angerechtigkeit
erst Ungerechtigkeit ist was ist primär
ist eine spannende Frage dann natürlich
auch heute vor allem sichtbar wir haben
das schon bisschen bei Thomas Herbst
gesehen als es uns um vertragstheorien
dienen Gerechtigkeit wäre es recht das
hängt natürlich mit der Frage zusammen
Moral versus Recht oder auch ewig vs
recht ähm also ist Gerechtigkeit eine
Kategorie der Ethik ist gerecht ein
Moral dieses Prädikat eine Eigenschaft
eine moralische Eigenschaft oder ist es
eher eine Eigenschaft die
in dem Bereich des Rechts gehört also
nicht so sehr die Moral betrifft und das
ist eben wieder hier dieses Thema
Gerechtigkeit als juristischer und
philosophischer Begriff
jede juristische Untersuchung der
Gerechtigkeit kommt nicht dabei darum
vorbei auch den philosophischen Begriff
oder auch den ethischen Begriff der
Gerechtigkeit zu behandeln wir müssen
beim recht sind dann spielt natürlich
auch die Unterscheidung zwischen
Naturrecht und positiven Recht eine ganz
zentrale Rolle Naturrecht sagt eben das
Recht ist in dem Wesen in den
Wesenheiten im Wesen des Menschen
vielleicht aber auch in natürlichen
Phänomenen enthalten als solches ohne
menschliche Konstruktion ohne
menschliche Konzeption und das positive
Recht sagt nein
Recht ist Menschen gemacht also gesetzt
daher kommt diese positive von
lateinisch tonere setzen das ist recht
was gesetzt wurde von Menschen
als Kompromiss oder was auch immer da
kann man dann wieder auf mietsche
eingehen aber es ist nichts was
ursprünglich da ist was wir vorfinden
ist etwas was wir künstlich erzeugen als
nächstes geht es dann um das Thema
Gerechtigkeit und da haben wir hier
diese schöne Allegorie gesehen von der
Justizia mit verschiedenen Eigenschaften
die die Gerechtigkeit abstrakt hat
interessieren wir haben gesehen dass
hier eine Augenbinde zu sehen ist wir
haben die geht
symbolisch oder metaphorisch allegorisch
natürlich am Ende gilt sie für die
Neutralität sie schaut nicht auf
Äußerlichkeiten sie versucht objektiv zu
sein dann haben wir hier die Waage
gesehen das ist die Urteilsfindung die
Urteilskraft des abwägen Truhen contra
die eben Urteilsbildung die ist nicht so
leicht und hier das Schwert darüber
haben uns auch unterhalten ist es ja die
Vollstreckung des Urteils dann wird es
aber ja eigentlich die Exekutive oder
ist es eher so diese Verbindlichkeit des
Urteils ja diese
Unbestechlichkeit nicht nur Bezug auf
die Augenbinde sein die Entschiedenheit
des Urteils das hier nicht mehr mit ihr
geredet werden kann wenn das Urteil
einmal gefällt würde dann steht das und
so kann man auch diese stehende Schwert
interpretieren diese Schärfe und
Unbeugsamkeit die ja auch ein bisschen
was von Wehrhaftigkeit hat da kann man
groß darüber diskutieren jedenfalls sind
diese ganzen
allegorischen Eigenschaften sehr wichtig
diese Aspekte von Gerechtigkeit also
Objektivität
Urteil Begründung Rechtfertigung also
Rationalität
gehört dazu und eben auch die
Unbestechlichkeit hat die Unbeugsamkeit
im also die die für die Gerechtigkeit
gilt natürlich kann man jetzt wieder mit
Natur sagen das ist doch alles eine
bloße Stilisierung von ursprünglich ganz
banalen bei Phänomenen wie Angst oder
wie Feigheit das betrifft generell die
Frage von Genese und Geltung selbst wenn
das Konzepte Gerechtigkeit durch
Feigheit oder überlebenstrang oder was
weiß ich am Ende dann gebildet worden
sein heißt es ja noch lange nicht dass
der Begriff oder das Konzept sinnlos ist
ja also die Genese die etwas unedle
Herkunft vielleicht der
gerechtigkeitskonzeption heißt ja nicht
dass sie am Ende dann auch sinnvoll sein
kann also das muss man immer auch
kritisch sehen Genese und Geltung
überhaupt Geltung ist auch ein wichtiger
Begriff weil eben auch Gerechtigkeit mit
dem Begriff der Norm zu tun hat Normen
Normen und Werte und Normen gelten ja
die haben eine Geltung und möglichst
eine objektive Geltung Zeit übergreifend
das würde natürlich dann mit einer
genetischen Ansicht so nicht gut
zusammenpassen
kann man sich auch noch fragen was ist
politische Gerechtigkeit was macht unser
Handeln gerecht woran erkennen wir
überhaupt das etwas gerecht ist was kann
überhaupt gerecht sein sind das
intersubjektives Strukturen oder ist es
nur individuelle sind es nur
individuelle Angelegenheiten
Ungerechtigkeit und Ungleichheit
Gerechtigkeit und Gleichheit müssen wir
uns auch überlegen das Problem der
Gleichheit sehen wir gleich ist sehr
groß gleich hat ist nämlich ein sehr
relativer Begriff und so tut auch
Gerechtigkeit ein sehr relative Begriff
zu werden wie verhalten sich Neid und
Gerechtigkeit zueinander das betrifft
die Frage auch einerseits nach
sozialheit
der sich immer auf das Prinzip der
Gerechtigkeit beruft und sagt deswegen
habe ich das jetzt kritisiert weil
ungerecht Zustände vorherrschen dann
kann man Gerechtigkeit verschiedentlich
aufpassen als Tugend das macht eben
Platon und vor allem Aristoteles
Gerechtigkeit ist ich habe schon kurz
gesagt ein normativer Begriff
normativ heißt er beschreibt nicht nur
das wäre deskriptiv sondern er fordert
er ergibt Kriterien für die Bildung als
ein normativer Begriff der nicht
unbedingt gleich moralisch zu verstehen
sein muss Gerechtigkeit wird häufig auch
im idealistisch gefasst als Ideal was
am Ende erlangt werden soll was aber
vielleicht noch in weiter Ferne schwebt
oder noch Garten oder gar nie wirklich
verwirklicht werden kann
dann Gerechtigkeit und Rechtfertigung
ist auch ein wichtiges Thema wir müssen
wie wir gesehen haben bei der Allegorie
wenn wir etwas zu einem Urteil kommen
dass etwas gerecht ist oder um überhaupt
zum Urteil zu kommen dass etwas gerecht
ist müssen wir Gründe anführen
wir müssen wenn wir gegen
Ungerechtigkeit argumentieren natürlich
auch Gründe angeben oder wenn wir
überhaupt feststellen wollen was gerecht
ist müssen wir das durch rationale
Überlegung erzielen das nennt man häufig
Rechtfertigung Gründe zu geben für eine
Ansicht ja Gerechtigkeit als Tugend das
wäre eine erstrebenswerte
Charaktereigenschaft
wird häufig im Kontext von anderen
Kardinaltugenden diskutiert ich habe
schon gesagt Gerechtigkeit ist ein
heiser Kandidat für diese
Kardinaltugend also die wichtigste
Tugend einer der obersten Tugenden es
gibt noch andere Tugenden Mäßigung
Tapferkeit haben wir schon gesehen
Weisheit dass wir jetzt eine
dianoetische Tugend also eine Tugend die
man durch Belehrung erlangt oder auch
vorne ist die Klugheit wir haben hier
auch noch die Gerechtigkeit eben als
normativer Begriff und der betrifft
jetzt auch den Gedanken der Gleichheit
Gerechtigkeit ist ein relationaler und
situativer Begriff das heißt was gerecht
ist hängt häufig von den Umständen ab
das heißt jetzt nicht das Gerechtigkeit
relativ ist aber dass wir von gerichtete
ungerecht immer nur dann sprechen können
wenn wir vergleichbare Umstände haben
ich habe schon mal ein Beispiel gebracht
sich selbst mit Arnold Schwarzenegger zu
vergleichen geht für die allerwenigsten
Menschen
weil sie eben nicht so muskulös sind und
deswegen können
Gerechtigkeitsfragen eigentlich nur da
ansetzen wo man eine ähnliche
Physiologie hat wie Arnold
Schwarzenegger alles andere ist dann
schwierig man kann jetzt natürlich sagen
es ist ungerecht dass Arnold
Schwarzenegger von Natur aus diese
diesen Körperbau hatte wenn man das
überhaupt als wünschenswert empfindet
ist eine ganz andere Frage wenn man sich
jetzt aber mit ihm vergleicht dann
müsste man oben da sozusagen das ist
ungerecht irgendwie eine eine Schuldige
Instanz finden warum man selbst eben
nicht daran kommt und dann wird es
irgendwann absurd dass man irgendwie in
der Natur die Schuld gibt dass sie einem
irgendwie nicht diese diesen Körper hat
zukommen lassen wenn man das überhaupt
will anders wird dann wenn z.B in gerade
sportlicher Hinsicht wenn es um Leistung
geht
Bodybuilding geht ja auch so ein
bisschen diese Leistung wenn man sich
dann mit unerlaubten Hilfsmitteln hilft
eben besser zu werden als andere die
eigentlich ähnliche vergleichbare
Leistungen
und hier kommt dann der Gedanke ist im
Spiel hat dass man sagt das ist doch
unfair
da wird mit unlauteren Mitteln im
Wettbewerb gekämpft also gerade auch in
vergleichssituationen im kompetitiven
Wettbewerbssituation hat der Begriff der
Gerechtigkeit eine wichtige Bedeutung
häufig im Sinne der Fairness des
fairplays
also nicht mit unerlaubten Mitteln
operieren sondern da muss dann nur die
Leistung soll zählen
ja der Gerechtigkeit liegt der Gedanke
der Gleichheit zugrunde die bewahrt oder
hergestellt werden soll natürlich heißt
Gleichheit es muss auch überhaupt
vergleichbar sein ich kann nicht jede
Person kann sich mit Arnold
Schwarzenegger vergleichen mit dieser
Physiologie weil nicht jeder das hat ob
das jetzt gerecht ist oder ungerecht es
ist eine andere Frage aber irgendwann
wird die Frage ab sofort wenn man sich
vergleicht mit Leistungen Menschen die
einfach gar keine wirkliche
Vergleichsbasis mehr haben irgendwann
gibt es eine vergleichbar es ist dass
man sagt das ist die Natur die da
Unrecht war aber dann kann man wirklich
die Natur ein Vorwurf machen ein
normativen vielleicht sogar moralischen
Vorwurf hat die Natur zu uns
benachteiligen wollen die wir nicht
diesen Körper wie Arnold schwarz
schwierig anders ist es wenn eben im
Wettbewerbssituation wo man eigentlich
ähnlich gut ist eine andere Person
unterstellen kann dass sie nicht mit
lauter dass sie nur mit unlauteren
Mitteln zu ihrem Erfolg kam und man
sozusagen benachteiligt wurde ja also
hier spricht der Begriff der Fairness
eine große Rolle das ist auch noch ein
wichtiger Punkt soziale Strukturen
können auch als Gericht oder ungerecht
bezeichnet werden das müssen nicht nur
Personen oder Handlungen zahlen also
überhaupt die Frage der Ontologie der
Gerechtigkeit
erstens wie existiert Gerechtigkeit
als Norm existiert sie wie ein Ding wie
ein Vertrag
existiert sie wie in ein Ideal oder
existiert sie nur im Sinne der Geltung
sie existiert eigentlich gar nicht
sondern sie hat nur gelungen oder hat
nicht Geltung
und dann wer kommt in Frage Gericht
genannt zu werden Personen Handlungen
ein Wille wir haben das in diesen
Quizfragen auch diskutiert nicht alles
kann gerecht werden was Menschen
betrifft dann möchte ich hier noch auf
einen wichtigen Artikel Hinweisen in der
Stanford and cycloud video of the da
finden sie immer ganz zentrale Begriffe
wie eben auch zum Begriff der
Gerechtigkeit eben auch auf Englisch mit
der aktuellen Diskussion jetzt komme ich
auf die
Denkerinnen und Denker der heutigen
Sitzung und auch der morgigen Sitzung
kurz noch zu sprechen wir sehen wir
hatten als letzte Position den Friedrich
Nietzsche behandelt wir hatten auch den
Karl Marx behandelt das heißt wir waren
schon im 19 Jahrhundert unterwegs und
jetzt mit der heutigen Sitzung gegenüber
ins 20 Jahrhundert mit Hans Kehl sende
dürfte der ein oder anderen Teilnehmerin
bekannt sein was hat es hier mit
Aufsicht Hans Kehl sind war einer der
bedeutendsten Juristen muss man sagen
oder genau vielleicht rechts Theoretiker
das heißt er hat sich stark mit der
Gerechtigkeit aus der Perspektive des
Rechts befasst genau genommen aus
Perspektive des Rechts Positivismus also
recht ist etwas von Menschen gesetztes
hat eine konstruktive Seite ein weiterer
wichtiger Punkt ist der Begriff der
Grundnorm darauf werden wir dann auch im
Text heute genauer eingehen Grundnorm
bedeutet dass alle Normen die gelten
alle rechtlichen vielleicht auch
moralischen Norm er spricht jetzt eher
von den Rechner dass die sich am Ende
auf eine allererste Norm zurückführen
lassen müssen weil sie ja sonst in der
Luft hängen man kann ja immer fragen wie
ich enorm begründet jetzt diese Namen
warum gilt diesen Namen oder warum
sollte diese Norm gelten dann kann man
ja immer weiter zurückgehen da gibt es
ein unendlichen Regress und er sagt
jetzt gewissermaßen fundamentalistisch
also jetzt logisch oder konzeptuell
fundamentalistisch wir brauchen eben ein
erstes Grund diese Grundnorm aus der
sich alles andere begründen lässt
kann man sich natürlich fragen ja kann
man diese Kunden auch dann wiederum
begründen oder wie warum gilt sie
welchen Status hat sie und er sagte dann
ist es eine eine Fiktion sagt der
teilweise und dann wird es dann
schwierig wie man da Basis von Fiktionen
eben auch Gerechtigkeit von dir kann
weitere wichtige Unterschied ist die
Unterscheidung zwischen Sein und sollen
also der sein ist das was existiert was
wir deskriptiv beschreiben können und es
sollen ist das was gilt also was
vielleicht auch noch nicht existiert was
er sein sollte und wir sehen da gibt es
einen großen Unterschied nicht alles was
ist
soll auch sein also das ist in
Unterschied den wir schon bei David jung
sehen auch bei Immanuel krank okay sind
bezieht sich vor allem auf Immanuel Kant
und natürlich ist auch noch die
Unterscheidung wichtig zwischen Recht
und Ethik dass wir das auseinanderhalten
er kommt natürlich eher vom Begriff des
Rechts
als nächste Person haben wir den HLA den
Herbert Lionels heart der hat auch im zu
Beginn des 20 Jahrhunderts viel bewirkt
ist auch ihr eine rechtstheoretiker und
er knüpft an kehlsen an das ist also
eine Kontinuität sein Hauptwerk ist der
concept of law aus dem Jahr 1961 also
schon zweite Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts
und auch da geht es letztendlich um den
rechts Positivismus der aber jetzt weil
er aus dem angelsächsischen Bereich
kommt stärker beeinflusst ist von
bentent also dem
utilitarristen oder auch relativ spielen
hier eine Rolle das ist dann sozusagen
die angelsächsische oder auch
analytische rechts positiv
so lange sächsischen Bereich also
jeweils spielen da auch die
geistesgeschichtlichen Hintergründe eine
Rolle hier steht der Begriff des Rechts
im Zentrum rechts Positivismus nicht
Naturrecht sondern Menschen gemacht des
menschengesetzes Recht als nächstes
wollen wir dann heute noch falls möglich
uns mit John walls befassen der hat ja
wie sie alle wissen eine Theorie der
Gerechtigkeit geschrieben er ist
vielleicht der wichtigste politische
Philosoph des 20 Jahrhunderts
Liberalismus spielt eine Rolle aber eben
auch Gerechtigkeit und Fairness den
Begriff hatten wir schon darüber
versuchte Gerechtigkeit zu erklären und
dann geht es auch noch stark und die
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit wie geht man
mit begrenzten Gütern so um das
möglichst alle etwas abbekommen und zwar
eben auf gleiche oder besser gesagt
gerechte Weise Jürgen habermaß der noch
lebende deutsche Philosoph
hat dann Gerechtigkeit Stärke über den
Begriff der Rationalität wird der
Vernunft versucht zu begründen wichtig
ist für Jürgen Habermas auch die
Auffassung von Sprache als kommunikative
Rationalität an der sprachaspekt ist für
ihn ganz ganz wichtig bei seiner
generellen Philosophie hat eine Theorie
des kommunikativen Handelns verfasst
also wir handeln indem wir kommunizieren
und jetzt kann man sich fragen wie
können wir gerecht handeln wenn wir
kommunizieren das ist ganz wichtig für
ihn dann gibt es noch andere Akzente
amatia Sam ein ursprünglich indischer ja
Ökonom muss man schon sagen der jetzt
Gerechtigkeit auch so ein bisschen von
rolls comment
gerechtigkeitsverteilungstheorie eben
auf die ökonomischen Verhältnisse
bezieht und noch weiter gedacht eben
auch auf globale Gerechtigkeit ja also
Gerechtigkeit jetzt
größtmöglichste
Ausgestaltung die ganze gewählt betrifft
und zum Schluss lesen wir von Marder
Nussbaum
Ausschnitte aus ihrem relativ neuen Buch
mit dem Titel die Grenzen der
Gerechtigkeit Untertitel Behinderung
Nationalität und Spezies Zugehörigkeit
das finde ich ganz wichtig dass Sie auch
mal von den Grenzen ausgeht man könnte
das eigentlich auch nennen Formen der
Ungerechtigkeit und sie spricht jetzt
nicht nur so abstrakt davon sondern sie
nimmt Bezug ganz konkret auf
verschiedene Formen man könnte auch
sprechen von Diskriminierung das sagt
sie jetzt nicht aber auch
Diskriminierung und Ungerechtigkeit
hängt natürlich zusammen und sie nimmt
hier verschiedene Formen in den Blick
spannend finde ich jetzt hier eben auch
die Spezies Zugehörigkeit damit meint
sie eben das verschiedene Lebensformen
also Menschen aber auch eben nicht
menschliche Tiere immer auch ger
gehandelt werden sollten und im
Anschluss an Peter Singer den bekannten
tierethiker wird sie auch die These
vertreten dass wir nicht einfach nur
deswegen weil wir Menschen sind weil wir
zu Spezies Mensch zählen andere nicht
menschliche Lebensform irgendwie gleich
ungerecht behandeln dürfen was auch
jetzt immer ungerecht hier heißt dass
wir einem alles mit ihm tun dürfen
sondern auch hier müssen
Gerechtigkeitsprinzipien gelten bisher
haben wir Gerechtigkeit nur diskutiert
mit Blick auf den Menschen oder
menschliche Erzeugnisse sie dient jetzt
den Gerechtigkeitsbegriff aus und das
ist sicherlich sehr sehr wichtig auch
vor dem Hintergrund der Frage nach
Ungerechtigkeit ja das war jetzt eine
kurze
Einführung ich bedanke mich für die
Aufmerksamkeit und stoppe jetzt die
Aufzeichnung so dass wir jetzt gleich
weiter diskutieren können